did you really spend nine or ten years
in your 40s trying to raise money for a
film no I tried amazing money the first
time trying to raise money for anything
was I was in my 50s already
and nobody wants to give any money
because if they're a professional
investor
and they know what they're doing
they're not going to invest in a movie
but they don't want to take a risk and
the risk a movie is the highest risk
thing risk
Venture you can get into
so you would have to get I found that
the most likely people to invest in a
movie were people who loved movies
and all their life secretly or not too
secretly wanted to be a part of a movie
but never had the chance or pass up the
chance people that had big film
collections in their basements
people used to play in rock and roll
bands and used and they missed
performing in front of a group
other people just want to meet the
pretty girls actresses at the parties
but almost every time and this is where
raising like five hundred dollars or two
hundred dollars or a thousand Maybe
that at the very last minute they you
know they would live the life up until
that point where they had to write to
check when they had to write to check
then it was a different story
and then somebody their husband their
wife or their business manager or best
friend
would tell them that it's a risk
and in one case we had a guy who I
talked to from in Chicago when I was
there
and six months later he was coming to
Los Angeles so we really did our
homework we did a we did offices with
storyboard out on the wall and actress
actors photos and things
the night before he called me up and
said I'll see you tomorrow at 10 A.M I'm
really excited about this next morning
at nine o'clock my wife said I can't do
it
another time I we did a whole dog and
pony show right here in my house we had
a party with this one guy from the
Middle East he came in and he was really
excited and we had I had girls dressed
as sexy cave girls and fur bikinis and
we had food we had drinks we were I had
a videotape I put together that went for
hours there's nothing but clips from
dinosaur movies and he was all Jazz and
the next day he decided no
I I think there's money I mean I I'm
going to invest this money in property
in Malibu or Santa Monica or somewhere
which about a week later all went down
in the flood so we lost everything so I
found out that these people the big
talkers with the big Bank rolls they're
the least likely people to put money in
and so what I did when I after spending
over a decade beating my head against
while trying to get people to put money
in movies and and sometimes like I knew
Jurassic Park was in the 1994 I knew
Jurassic Park was around the corner I
had a friend who ran ilm industrial
Light and magic and he was telling me
what a big thing this was going to be
and I knew everything was going to go
dinosaur Roger Corman who was who knew
made a cheap movie called carnosaur
which ironically I got to work on is a
dinosaur consultant and um Corman made
this movie
for like
I don't know 10 million dollars he put
it out a week before a Jurassic Park
when everybody was already primed up for
a dinosaur movie and it made 10 times
this money back in about a week I'm
still trying to raise money for my my
dinosaur film which finally came out
like two years later and it was we'd
missed the boat because everybody I said
Jurassic Park too
they looked at me like I was crazy
what's what is that drastic what is that
and um so the people I knew weren't the
people they were likely then to put
money into it and then the people that
did put money into it a lot of them
didn't understand that it was a risk and
uh thought they were going to become
instant millionaires which never
happened and
threatened us with lawsuits and called
us up at all hours of the morning uh
well as all hours of the night
and finally after making six movies
going through that process
I was at my high school Union in Chicago
Chicago
and I was thinking
I want to make another movie I can't let
another year go by without making
another movie I'm not getting any
younger you know I wonder
but I got this huge comic book
collection with things like first issues
of Superman and Batman and Wonder Woman
I don't care about those Comics anymore
I never look at them they're just
sitting on a shelf I sold them all I
raised enough money to
uh to finance my own movie and that's
what I did from that point in I financed
two movies now I have no investors to
annoy me or who don't
understand the contract which they never
read or
you know I can do it on my own I I don't
have any business partners I don't have
to argue with what I think is going to
be the next genre around the next Trend
around the corner and um everything
worked out nice so if the movie makes
its money back I don't have to share it
with anybody if it bombs I don't have
anybody to answer to but I still had
that wonderful experience of making a
movie seeing it all come together one
step by The Next Step
seeing it all come you know when you
start out you got an ID in your head you
can see the movie in your head
when it's all done you can see it on the
screen and how close
what you're seeing what you're watching
resembles what you're originally
imagined and if it's close or even
halfway close that's a great Rush that's
a great feeling
so you felt that no one would take you
seriously at 50 or after no that's what
I thought because I was on the
Mountaintop we were scouting locations
for Dinosaur Valley girls I was in a
Mountaintop looking down into the valley
and besides that
I said
at my age am I going to be physically
able to do this I'm going to be running
up and down Hills and climbing and all
this sort of thing and shooting 13 14
maybe 15 hours a day can I do this will
I survive it and I survived it just fine
with a lot of movies after that
what do you say to someone who worries
that they have to make a movie before
age 30. I tell them look at my website
and you'll see eight of them that I made
after 50. and I make if I had the money
now I would make I would be shooting a
movie right now I got two scripts ready
to go but
I can't make a movie like some of these
people where they make a movie for 500
in their backyard and call that a movie
shot on videotape I spent at least 150
000 when I make a movie I hire sag
actors
pay them sag wages and all that we pay
for permits when we have to
um I do it the right way but they're
still low budget and we try to make them
look take the costs a million dollars
um
but I think that's an excuse
you know I think when people say like
nobody's going to buy my story anymore
I'm
taking I mean the studios might not if
you're going through the studio system
whether you're writing for television or
for movies yeah then you have a big
worry because they want to have not only
people that they think have not been
burned out as far as their ideas go they
also want people that look good I don't
mean necessarily handsome or beautiful
but look sharp they aren't
you know drastically overweight they
don't dress sloppy you know because it's
a cosmetic business when they when
people walk through those corridors and
they looked in the window it looked as
they were seeing somebody running the
Xerox machine or behind the desk they
want somebody that looks young and sharp
you see a lot of attractive women a lot
of handsome men in those places dress
nicely you know
and that's one thing they should
uh consider their own personal
appearance when they because they say
and it's very true I think first
impressions are lasting
think of how many friends you have
that that are
40 years old
that you've known since you were a kid
and they call you up on the phone and
the first image that pops into your mind
is them as that little kid
you know that happens to me all the time
and um so those first impressions are
really really important